I do not say ever wonder who's behind
the hilarious voices of your favorite
vampire family Hotel Transylvania has
become a huge franchise since the first
movie was released back in 2012 it's
gone on to produce two more sequels and
recently announced part four is on the
way
while we are totally invested in the
captivating Adventures of characters
like Dracula Mavis and all of their
monster friends we guarantee that you'll
be shocked when you hear just what
star-studded celebs are behind the
voices of your favorite animations how
could we start with anyone other than
the scary Count Dracula himself this
voice actor might have been a little
difficult for viewers to figure out just
because of his stellar fake accent
you've most likely watched this
Hollywood celebs the star in plenty of
comedies and usually he's featured
alongside nineties icons like Jennifer
Aniston and drew Barrymore uh any
guesses that's right it's Adam Sandler
Sandler has starred in all three films
so far and is slated to star in the
upcoming fourth movie we knew Dracula's
actor couldn't have been that
intimidating if you loved his work as
Dracula you can spot him in movies like
grown-ups just go with it and 50 first
dates he's just a normal hotel nothing
going on here the lovable Mavis is next
she might just be less scary than her
father even if she can turn into a bat
if you grew up watching 2000's Disney
you definitely know who the actress is
behind this vampire s let's just say
that this is not her first rodeo when it
comes to starring in a supernatural
production from Disney start a
world-renowned pop star this celeb has
become a household name the one and only
Selena Gomez like Sandler she worked in
all three films and will reportedly be
returning for a fourth fun fact Adam
Sandler actually recruited his daughter
Sadie Sandler to voice the young version
of Mavis you don't need to be frightened
just like Mavis and eventually Dracula
we all fell in love with the clumsy and
very human Jonathan while his actor
doesn't have flaming red air
Jonathan's goofiness can definitely be
seen in some of his other projects like
Brooklyn
9:00 and Saturday Night Live Hotel
Transylvania is just more of a g-rated
take on his humour its California is
very own Andy Samberg he's a start
alongside Gomez and Sandler for the past
three movies but has yet to be announced
for the fourth fingers crossed your dad
is going to love this
Murray The Mummy is so epic that he's
had two famous celebs bring his voice to
life no pun intended in the first film
Murray was played by a 2000s music star
turned writer and producer but after
wrapping part 1 this singer put his
famous lyric to action and said forget
you who could have ever guessed that he
was originally played by Cee Lo Green
Murray in parts 2 & 3 had even more
flavor you might recognize this voice
from another more adult cartoon called
Rick and Morty or even in some smaller
roles in Disney cartoons like Toy Story
4 and The Lion King keegan-michael key
who do you think played Murray better
super cursed only the best straight from
the crib the actor behind Frankenstein
might be considered almost as iconic in
the comedy world as Sandler himself
whether you've seen him in movies like
paul blart mall cop or grown-up solar
and his long-running series the king of
queens
he's undoubtedly made you giggle who
knew we would see the day Kevin James
would voice a cartoon in a children's
movie
he's been providing Hotel Transylvania
fans with laughter since 2012 just like
the rest of the og characters there's
been no news on whether he'll be
returning as one of Dracula's sidekicks
for the fourth film so you still want to
hang with us we couldn't have
Frankenstein without the Bride of
Frankenstein or as Hotel Transylvania
fans know her Eunice this character is a
little less known compared to her
counterparts but just as hilarious from
working in productions like The Nanny
and happily divorced Fran Drescher has
been bringing her humor to the big
screen since the very beginning of the
franchise I think that we can all agree
that she's the perfect partner for
Frankenstein everybody just please watch
the ham Griffon is played by yet another
grown-ups alumni at this point Hotel
Transylvania should just be renamed a
grown-ups reunion this actor has worked
closely with Adam Sandler multiple times
even starring in multiple films from
Sandler's production company happy
madison films he recently released a new
netflix movie it's called the wrong miss
and has lent his talents to classic
episodes of Saturday Night Live it's
David Spade everyone we couldn't imagine
anyone else playing the iconic Invisible
Man for the past three films but you're
the one in denial haha
Wanda might just be a werewolf in all
three Hotel Transylvania films but in
real life she's well-known for so many
hit TV shows and blockbuster movies
brahms starring in the series Will &
Grace to having a role in movies like
the Santa Claus - Shallow Hal and scary
movie you might say that she's a
superstar that's right its iconic 90s
and 2000 star Molly Shannon hopefully
she returns for the fourth film I think
we do whatever we want this next
character was only featured in the third
film but she definitely left her mark as
the main antagonist Erika van Helsing
while this actress might have a hard
time topping her evil cruise director
role in the Hotel Transylvania films she
has a resume stacked with rules and
other huge movies you might have spotted
her in blockbuster hits like bad moms
Tomorrowland and stepbrothers Kathryn
Hahn is her name Hotel Transylvania
Gaston director needs a major award ASAP
the sole lab behind Wayne's character
has plenty of experience and voice
acting in fact he's a pretty important
character in another little animated
franchise called monsters Inc you may
have heard of it not only does Steve
Buscemi have the honor of playing
Wanda's husband but he's also the voice
actor behind Randall from the Monsters
Inc films you can also catch him
alongside Adam Sandler and the 90s film
Big Daddy
it really does seem like Adam Sandler
just rounded up all of his past co-stars
and gave them roles
maybe we're not complaining he also is
it us or our Wayne and Randall actually
super similar characters no that's
better than nothing
if we need a more proof that Adam
Sandler called the shots when it came to
Casting we only have to look at the
voice behind Wanda and Wayne's daughter
Winnie you guessed it it's his daughter
Sadie again she got the opportunity to
voice not one but two characters in all
three films and Adam Sandler adopted us
she's also had roles in films like just
go with it the wrong Missy and grownups
[Music]
you'll never guess the voice behind the
character of Kraken who was featured in
the third film he may not be a Hollywood
actor but he's definitely left his mark
in the world of music we'll give you a
hint he sings in a band alongside his
two brothers and may or may not have got
to start as a Disney star Joe Jonas did
you guess the right Jonas huh it's only
fitting that he'd lend his vocal talents
for the film we couldn't think of anyone
better to give us that comedic relief
voice actors come in all ages for this
movie including this Hollywood veteran
who lent his experience to the role of
Vlad they definitely needed someone
experienced to play a villain in the
second film and that a hero in the next
not to mention he would have to rival
out of sailor for playing the best
vampire you may remember him for the
retro movie space balls or recognize his
voice from the original Muppets
drumroll please it's Mel Brooks would
love to hear more quote my people models
were not excluded from this cast roster
either Krystal who was featured in the
third film was voiced by a previous
Sports Illustrated model she also
happens to be a huge internet
personality known for her candid but
hilarious posts need some more hints
she's married to brandy award-winning
artist John Legend ah yeah you know it
Chrissy Teigen at your service although
her character was invisible just her
voice alone brought the spunk the movie
needed not to mention it proved that
Griffin really did have a girlfriend
this is like the nicest hotel I've ever
been to we couldn't make this video
without giving you all the deets on
Mavis and Jonathan's son the very
adorable Dennis he may not be your
traditional vampire but his actor played
him perfectly especially considering
that he was only six when the second
film was made asher blink off has also
used his young talent in films like the
jungle book live-action and the
children's cartoon sing just look how
cute he is this is Bob say hi Bob
good old Stan the third film wouldn't
have been the same without him while he
wasn't featured in the first two films
his voice actor actually was this celeb
not only worked out Stan but brought the
character fly from the first two films
to life as well you've definitely seen
this actor around he's worked in
productions like grown ish and 21 Jump
Street and he got his start in voice
acting and shows like Family Guy and
Rick and Morty tada it's Chris Parnell
welcome to the Bermuda Triangle Bela
maybe only in the second film but Vlad
just wouldn't have seemed as evil
without him he was truly the mastermind
behind all of Vlad's plans it's no
wonder that they had such an experienced
actor to fill in the role with a resume
packed with credits like The Daily Show
Modern Family and Brooklyn nine-nine
Rob Riggle was the obvious choice we
wouldn't blame you if you totally missed
him in the third film doesn't anybody
past Saturday Night Live actors aren't
lacking when it comes to this cast Dana
from Hotel Transylvania 2 was played by
an SNL veteran that your parents almost
two definitely know he also lent his
voice talents to hilarious animated
films like Life of pets and the 1992
comedy Wayne's World alongside Mike
Myers also known as Shrek Dana Carvey
has definitely learned from the past
while his role is small in Hotel
Transylvania
it's definitely hilarious who else could
train a bunch of baby vampires
okey dokey see you at the campfire the
Phantom of the Opera is here and he's
voiced by of course another Hollywood
celeb it looks like Hotel Transylvania
even set a standard of casting for their
minor characters you undoubtably of
laughed at this actor's hilarious jokes
and his roles on Saturday Night Live for
the Simpsons Netflix is insatiable and
grownups too it's Jon Lovitz who knew a
stand-up comedian would be the one to
play the mysterious phantom of the
opera' not us
bird the phantom may have only been
around in the second movie but Jon
Lovitz has been around for longer in the
first film he also voiced to the eerie
character Quasimodo they don't even
sound similar this is just too much
talent for us to handle remember how we
told you that Adam Sandler's daughter
played a pretty big role in the
franchise Wow she wasn't the only one in
the family who scored a role in the
movies it's a family affair
can you guess who voiced the character
Martha in the first films she was also
given roles in movies like grown-ups the
wrong missy paul blart mall cop and Big
Daddy it's his wife Jackie Sandler of
course it's fitting that she would also
play his on-screen wife even if it was
an animated film you never know when
your favorite blockbuster movie star is
the voice behind these cartoons and they
definitely add another layer to these
iconic characters who is your favorite
Hotel Transylvania character did you
know there voice actor even before
watching this video which reveal was the
most shocking let us know in the comment
section below
we can't wait to hear your thoughts oh
and hey don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up if you're looking for more
videos just like this one on the things
we'll see you next time
you